this is Rivers he's wading through a
pool of waste beneath one of the largest
aquariums in the world Georgia Aquarium
it's a filthy job
but that's not the only challenge
there's a lot of ways to manage when
this Basin is full it can hold between
five to ten thousand gallons of poop
that funnels here from the aquarium's
habitats and it's the culmination of
many routine cleaning procedures that
happen at the aquarium each week without
which the safety and health of the
animals would be at risk
by the time rivers and his team's work
here is complete the Wastewater from
this Basin will be cleaned filtered and
reused as top off water for the
aquarium's largest exhibit ocean Voyager
and the cleaning cycle will Begin Again
but before Rivers can do his job several
other critical procedures have to happen
first every day specialized teams gear
up to clean the hundreds of exhibits at
the aquarium
one of the first you'll see when you
enter the aquarium is the sea lion
exhibit which is home to this guy Toby a
279 pound harbor seal before a team of
divers can begin cleaning his habitat
Toby and the other sea lions need to
vacate their pools staffers use this
time to do their weekly weigh-ins and if
we're talking about Dirty Jobs he just
urinated on the scale and now we got to
clean it side effect of the job
this pool it's all sea lion poop it's
all sea lion poop everything that she's
vacuuming from here is going into that
waste Basin so whatever we do in here to
LSS our life support team then has to
clean up from their end Megan Wade leads
the pinnapets team to clean the decks
and assist the dive operations team as
they clean the pools before guests
arrive
this space is home to 14 sea lions and
three harbor seals the sea lions can eat
five percent to eight percent of their
body weight making the sea lion exhibit
one of the dirtiest in the aquarium
every single morning we come in first
thing and prepare their food and this is
restaurant quality fish so they get
numerous species of fish about five
different species and every single
morning one or two people will come in
and inspect every single fish so we're
looking for missing eyes missing fins
gills scrapes Cuts anywhere where you're
gonna see that can breed bacteria so
that fish automatically gets sorted out
when we don't use it at all we weigh out
their food into buckets and then we'll
look at it again one last time before
feeding it to the animals once a week
every Wednesday it's way day Wednesday
follow me this way we have our blue
scale right here and then where the
green is lit up is going to tell us how
much they weigh so each sea lion will
walk from their habitat down this
hallway will get their weight and then
they'll walk back to their habitat
after the sea lions are fed weighed and
out of the main spaces Megan and the
team start working on cleaning the deck
areas her team splits up between the
back pools and the main Gallery where
they detail every nook and cranny
as soon as you come in in the morning
you can usually smell that they have
been sleeping overnight we have high up
platforms that they like to sleep on the
rocks and when you're sleeping and you
don't get up to go to the bathroom
it all just sits there so if we didn't
clean every single day it would be
really stinky kind of an ammonia smell
also there's fecal matter as well we are
going to detail this whole area it gets
cleaned every single day but we detail
it once a week every week three male sea
lions in one male harbor seal all slept
out here last night so it's probably
going to be pretty messy the chemicals
that we use are to really break up that
oil that's on the surface that the sea
lions secrete so it's just soap and
water and then we'll use some
chlorhexidine to disinfect the area
afterwards
and then down here Gail has a like a
nice little hand brush and she's
actually
doing one of the dirtiest jobs she's
cleaning the drains all of this is gonna
always be hosed to a drain away from the
water the sea lions swim in he's taking
the grates Off cleaning inside the drain
so that everything flows nicely each day
that we clean
so the drains are part of the detailing
the removal of the net and soaking
that's part of the detailing sea lions
when they breed sometimes shoot snot out
of their nose so a lot of times in sea
lion habitats you'll see brown snot on
the walls so we'll need to scrub that
off too my favorite part about cleaning
the deck is getting to net the poop out
of the water because I it just so
reinforcing when you do a good job and
you get good at it so I just love doing
it
after Megan in the pinnipeds team work
on the main Gallery deck Alex Glick and
a team of divers work on everything
below deck at the c-line exhibit today
you're going to start in pool two and
then do pull three this one's vacuuming
and floor scrubbing and then pull three
will be vacuuming Rock work and then a
final floor scrub so we do this dive on
uh just normal scuba even though it's
only an eight foot pool we still do
scuba diving so that you have freedom of
movement
this is our vacuum hose they actually
plug this in in the water and we have to
make a radio call to our life support
system and they'll turn the vacuum on
so we dropped the vacuum head in the
water with the hose attached to the
diver
and then they will Prime the hose to get
all the air out of the line this pool
it's all sea lion poop
you want to get as much vacuumed up
before you start scrubbing the floor
this scrubber is one of the key tools
the divers use to thoroughly clean
everything under the water
a hose pumps water through the engine
which Powers the scrubber this high
pressure water makes cleaning the floors
and walls much easier
the single scrubber has hard bristles
and is used for rock work while the
double brush scrubber is used to clean
the walls and painted surfaces once
she's done vacuuming I'll give this to
her and she will then clean the floor
and she's holding the trigger down and
she's swimming back and forth doing kind
of like a lawnmower motion cleaning one
side of the next to get every single
into the pool
if she comes across the area that's
particularly dirty she might slow down
and spend a little time on it to get up
whatever scum is on the bottom and then
move on
animal debris doesn't just settle on the
habitat's floors and surfaces it also
collects in grades and skimmer boxes
these outflows help manage waste between
routine cleanings by separating animals
from some of the debris in total it
takes Alex and his team of divers
roughly an hour to complete their work
in both pools
on the other side of the aquarium is
ocean Voyager the largest Indoor Aquatic
exhibit in the United States it holds
6.3 million gallons of water it is home
to whale sharks manta rays and thousands
of other fish this space is largely
dependent on an advanced life support
and filtration system but still relies
on teams for maintenance and Hands-On
cleaning in Ocean Voyager we have two
whale sharks there's yushan which is the
larger whale shark and then there's
taroko
common misconception about whale sharks
would be that they're dangerous the most
intimidating thing is they're just big
they just are big and so like if you're
in the way you just gotta move they are
not out to hurt you like their throat is
only the size of a quarter they're very
very docile creatures and they just want
to cruise along
we usually have four to eight divers in
our everyday maintenance dive we clean
the windows so we need our suction cup
we bring what we call a diaper otherwise
it just looks like a rag when we clean
the acrylic windows with that and then
usually we're doing hand scrubbing they
are scrubbing off the algae and they're
kind of basically wafting off all that
sand substrate that cakes on and falls
over onto those rocks all that stuff
that can grow on there is potentially
harmful for all the fish so the whole
goal of cleaning and upkeeping the
exhibit isn't necessarily to keep it
pretty even though that is also very
beneficial to keep it pretty for the
guests but at the same time there is the
purpose of doing it for the health of
the exhibit this is a monster exhibit so
if we didn't do it every day it'd be
pretty much impossible to upkeep the
blitz Dives which are our night Dives
that's our essential deep clean
so it could be a couple hours long just
to get everything we can done we can run
up to four of those our motto machines
and clean different areas of the exhibit
while ocean Voyager is being cleaned
Carolyn Murphy in the Aquarius team are
over at the river Scout Gallery getting
ready to dive into these three
freshwater tanks
the smallest tanks measure four feet
tall by three feet deep and the team
spends one to two hours every week
cleaning the windows and maintaining the
underwater Gardens here so despite the
size of these tanks we actually do or
manage to squeeze some people in there
what we are going to be doing is
something called hookah divings so the
diapers are getting in very carefully so
they're kind of sliding in the top of
the tank and they're going to be holding
themselves up in the water column by
pressing their feet to opposite of the
tank or putting them on the outside the
top rim and they'll kind of hold
themselves with their core strain kind
of up in the water column to do the work
they need to do
we're focusing on the algae that's
growing on the window and the plant
leaves and then also the detritus that's
building up in the tanks and that can be
Eagles from fish or leftover food
the team goes into the dive with a few
core tools a scrub brush trimming tools
and a fine plastic scraper to clean
algae off the windows
the most painstaking part for the
aquarists in this tank is cleaning out
the beard algae so it is so annoying and
it is something that we tediously tried
to keep under control so you're seeing
these little kind of black Puffs and
that's what she's targeting right now
when she's scraping it off and
immediately removing it from the system
because it will just spread over
everything
the divers use a gravity siphon to clean
out the loose debris that settled in the
gravel this isn't powered by electricity
it relies solely on gravity to suction
up and separate the waste from the
gravel
I'll do hovering everything doesn't look
great but it also can cause problems for
your fish so algae blooms in the wild
can kind of take the oxygen of the fish
need out of the system so it can cause
some harm for them that way
all the waste and debris from each of
these cleanings ends up here this is
cleaned out every three to four months
to ensure the Basin doesn't overflow it
doesn't create water quality issues and
all the systems continue to run smoothly
as you can see we've got
just piles of poop and debris and extra
food
stuff that didn't get digested properly
stuff that didn't get eaten got pulled
into filtration
most of it is just animal waste there is
a little bit of sand probably about 10 5
gallon buckets or so the equipment we'll
use to clean the Basin is a fire hose
and a snow shovel
cleaning this space takes roughly two to
three hours and is done in stages
they'll remove the poop clean the floors
and then shovel all the sand out once
we've gotten the sand out then we'll go
around and inspect the walls make sure
there's no cracks make sure the
waterproofing is still good so we're all
the discoloration happens is about where
the Basin gets roughly 55 to 60 000
gallons to a full Basin but other than
being gross the hardest part is
definitely getting the sand out just
because we've got to lift it 25 feet in
the air
though we really only want to film about
half full
if it were to get too full they might
Splat and they're also just really heavy
once this Basin is full we will then
recirculate all this water and clean
this water to reuse it for top off water
Burrows and Voyager exhibit after the
recovery all this water is Crystal Clean